money is oxygen for business I'm a
pretty altruistic fofy foofy let's all
love each other guy but if I can't make
pay roll all my good ideas aren't going
to matter anyway attention is the number
one asset it is a pleasure to have you
here at muss show today all the way from
New York City that's right and you
managed to fit Us in which is great now
on the podcast um we always kick things
off with a Juicy Business confession
okay yes how our guest have turned a
previous adversity or mistake into
action or a positive sort of drive for
growth in their own business so Gary yes
what is your business
confession um you know I think for
people that are
entrepreneurs and really actually I
think about this in the context of
life I think that we have it a little
bit misunderstood I think in general the
joury journey of the game of Business
and
Entrepreneurship is a constant flow of
micro losing with the occasional macro
win if it goes great you know so for me
confessions I mean there's been so many
mistakes I I as a matter of fact the
book that the audience has it's called
12 and a half it's because in the book I
talk about the fact that cander as a
leader has been very hard for me which
is always shocking for people who follow
me on social media because as Gary ve
cander is actually my ultimate strength
I get to it in this interview cander
will be my strength but in real life
when I'm an executive and really as a
human being the more I know you and care
about you the harder it was for me to
tell you the things that I was
struggling with that you were doing and
so I think about all the sloppy firings
in my 20s and 30s in my family wine
business and even in Vayner media early
on that could have done been done so
much more gracefully could have been so
much more clear I used to let people sit
around the company for 3 6 12 24 months
longer than they should have really
really and so I thought I was being a
good guy right I was saying like oh well
I'm paying them and they stink um and in
reality even 18 months later when
finally in a roundabout way they would
get fired they would be double angry and
it was cuz I wasn't able to give
feedback along the way I wasn't able to
be canderous so it's a huge huge
vulnerability that I'm so glad I'm
making progress on so you've changed
that now if someone's not doing
something
you you talked about this earlier do you
give them scope to improve or you just
say this is not working bang my you know
there's a lot to this this could maybe I
should lay down on this
couch my father who
I worked for from 14 to 34 was very good
at cander the problem was it was
delivered with Venom right and I wasn't
able to
discern the delivery mechanism from the
value of the cander so I demonized
cander because I viewed it as fear and I
think all of us here know that many
times when people have been given
critical feedback that person ran back
and went to their LinkedIn and started
looking for another job because we
didn't land C the reason I call it kind
cander is I think you know I have a lot
of respect for the concept of radical
cander I have a lot of concept respect
for cander but I think what is required
is kind
cander and now that now don't mistake
the word kind for delusional and
entitlement kind cander so it's a very
fine line to tell someone you are
falling short subjectively in my opinion
A lot of times When leaders leave
feedback to people and giving them
feedback they act as if it's absolute
truth it's absolute truth from their
subjective opinion but they happen to be
in a position where they have to make
that subjective
call so finding that balance has been
quite challenging but I've made a
million business mistakes I passed on
Uber twice in the angel round if I wrote
the normal 25 to $50,000 check that I
was writing back then as an investor I
would have made $500 million yeah that's
a big mistake that's a big mistake that
one
hurts but you've owned it and and you
move on or you you still talk about it
of course I talk about it because you
know people when people are like well
you invested in Facebook and Twitter and
Tumblr and like it can look real good
but like yes and I did really well but I
thought yo Bango was going to be the
biggest app I ever invested
in
now to my credit
yoongo was two years earlier than Tinder
and Tinder was a very big success so
when I saw yob Bango I'm like wait you
can know the people around you I'm like
yeah people are going to hook up you
know like and and I I I got it but what
I learned by passing on Uber and I
invested in Uber a little bit after that
but by the time the valuation changed it
changed my outcome dramatically still
very early my brother AJ took the first
Uber in Manhattan so it was early but it
wasn't early enough for this
gamechanging thing but in that window of
investing in yoongo because I loved the
idea and not investing in Uber early
enough because I underestimated what the
power of a good operator meant I learned
a lot which is today I invest first
based on what I think about the person
second about what I think about the
idea and that is is that how you find
those businesses that's what you look
for first yes because in that person
that you're looking for with my
subjective intuitive feel if they have
the stomach for the
game entrepreneurship is uncomfortably
lonely for all the people that are
sitting here that live in corporate jobs
and and put entrepreneurs or fantasize
about doing their own
thing you know people like Gary I want
to leave my job and be my own boss I'm
like being an entrepreneur and CEO means
everyone's your
boss I work for everyone that's sitting
in that front row and I really like feel
that like actually no [__] am I
allowed to curse no
oh what's great about entrepreneurship
is you make your own
rules so you know I think I think you
know the Grass Is Always Greener
entrepreneurship is my great passion I
spoke about it rapidly amassing my
audience and then I had to take a step
back 5 to seven years ago and say wait a
minute I grew up when entrepreneurship
was demonized and not even cool
everybody had to go to UNI and get great
grades now we've flipped too far in the
other direction I better start talking
about entrepreneurship is not for
everyone cuz it's not the amount of
people that go into entrepreneurship
because it's cool and then find
themselves incredibly depressed because
the thing about entrepreneurship is it's
like sports you can't hide when you fail
when you get fired at a job it's your
boss's fault
right but when you start a company and
it goes out of business there's nowhere
to hide and the world has fallen in love
with blaming everyone governments
parents companies systems social
networks the world has become remarkably
good at blaming everyone we do not like
accountability entrepreneurship is the
ultimate accountability I say to my
company all the time because it's true
100% of what's wrong at Vayner media is
100% my fault because it's true because
if you're mad at somebody over here or
over here well I hired that person or I
hired the person that hired that person
and I have the ability to do something
about it nobody in my company of the
2,000 employees globally has 100%
autonomy to do anything about it about
anything other than me so when you start
to understand understand what that game
is that is not for everyone so you're in
the game and it sounds like you're
pretty comfortable with being
uncomfortable
so why do you think it's important for
entrepreneurs to embrace discomfort to
succeed cuz there's no
option that was
it but I mean it right for the the pause
for effect is cuz there's no option the
only only thing when uh how many people
in the audience I know this is a podcast
and are listening this is I'm doing this
selfishly are parents raise your
hands when you become a parent something
changes you realize you're the last line
of defense for this
human and it changes it triggers
something in you your life changes you
don't sleep the same way there's
something else that you massively have
to worry about in addition to your own
safety well that's the truth of
Entrepreneurship like
especially when you go Global I have a
global company I what people like how do
you wake you know like everyone's
pushing us for healthier behavior and I
have a lot of great healthy behaviors I
sleep a ton which is always confusing to
people they think I'm one of these like
I don't I sleep six seven eight hours
cuz I need it cuz I'm on when I'm awake
I do I eat very clean I do a lot of good
things one thing I don't do that is
considered a good thing to do is the
second I wake up I grab my phone so fast
you couldn't even imagine not because I
want to because it's my responsibility I
have to look if anything happened in
Singapore or in s like it just it's my
responsibility I'm always on I we just
got out of the holidays it's my favorite
time when the whole world is off because
it's the only time that I can vacation I
can't take a normal vacation I have too
much responsibility because even if I
did take a week off next week I can't be
calm there's too much going on and I'm
going to come back to it it's not like
when I took like when you work somewhere
you leave like you can actually get away
from that week some way somehow not when
you own something so it's an intense
game uh but but why should they get
comfortable it's because they have no
options yeah now you touched on Gary the
essence of you a little bit now you saw
baseball cards as a child in New Jersey
you grew your father's wine business you
told us that and and you built up your
advertising agency V media so you're a
total entrepreneur through and through
but what is the thread through all your
experiences that have given us Gary
V I have a tremendous relationship with
losing I believe that the reason I'm
successful in life forget about my
business accomplishments the way I deem
my success in my life is I lack anxiety
compared to the majority of humans on
Earth I'm happy is completely and
utterly in association to my
relationship with
losing because I was born in the Soviet
Union and immigrated to the US and grew
up with very little because I grew up in
the 80s in America where you went
outside and you played and which means
you played games and you lost a lot
because I grew up outside in the 80s in
New Jersey I also got into fights
because that's that's what we used to do
you would fight because I got bad grades
by the time I was 18 years old I had
done so much
losing that I wasn't scared of it modern
society so over coddles everyone do you
know that we give away eighth place
trophies
now we have de the when PE today's work
today's world where everyone's like why
is everyone so anx it's co it's social
media no it's not it's modern
parenting the reason everyone's all bent
at of shape is in what was good
intent to making it good for our
children we created zoo
animals who then have to go into the
wild and get eaten by a lion in one
minute we've we've
overcorrected when you go to therapy
when you learn about life when
something's going on over here humans
tend to think the way to balance it is
to go over
here that's how we've gotten to where we
are but the answer is to go here the
reason you got Gary V is cuz my mother
is a
gangster she parented me perfectly she
put things like me being kind to people
on a pedestal not getting straight
A's when I got out of line there was
consequences remember some of the older
people in the
audience when you did something wrong
you would either get
smacked or if you got lucky you got
grounded for a week without video games
television and
friends today there's not even
grounding so what back to
entrepreneurship back to being resilient
back to being capable you have to deal
with adversity I dealt with so
much that what after dealing with all
that crap all that having every grown-up
in my childhood besides my mother tell
me I was going to be a loser cuz I got
D's and Fs between getting into fights
and growing up in tough neighborhoods
and going through all that you think
some random person on social media
saying that I'm an idiot is going to
bother
me is it about shutting out the noise
obviously but it's shutting out the
noise both ways on the flip side all
those lovely things you said about
me yeah I don't hear that
either don't you I sure don't the reason
reason that I'm capable of dealing with
negativity is because I don't overvalue
positivity either yeah if you get high
on the accolades and the cheering you
become vulnerable to the
booing so I'm aware that I'm good at
business so are lots of other people and
everyone I'm looking at and everyone
that's listening is also good and great
at other things too so I'm appreciative
I'm humbled it feels remarkable to be
living the life I'm living but I do not
think I am better than so do you think
that's a downfall of lots of successful
people yes money and fame and success
don't change people they expose them and
many people get to money Fame and
success fueled by
insecurity a smaller group The fortunate
ones get there through
gratitude and that is how the game is
played it's
beautiful now you're CEO in the fck
business um but what would you say is
the one thing that CEOs should be
doing I believe the majority of CEOs of
let's call it Fortune 50,000 so not just
500 not even just 5,000 but let's go
smaller B I would say the
50,000 largest businesses in the world
this the number one thing that I can tie
that I observe and I watch a lot on this
that the CEO should be doing more of
is spending more one-on-one time with
employees in their organization so are
you saying that you should be doing that
well I would tell you that if you looked
at my diary right now you would be
flabbergasted by how much one-on-one
time I have with my employees I would
argue that I spend more time on HR
actually I'm so I was about to say I
spend more time on HR than most things I
do as Co I'm going to take it to the
extreme I probably if you looked at my
calendar Diary of last year prob if I
broke down the time I spent on finance
with the CFO and the time I spent uh
with people in one-on-one and with my
pet team with this the people team
that's our HR department I would say the
breakdown of those two ratios and I'm
going to try to undersell it to not
hyperbolize it was
87% to
133% but that's one of the things
obviously working with the company and I
work with your team that's what they say
that you are very good at
that time you make people feel I I just
don't really I struggle with
understanding almost what else a CEO
should be
doing of course I know I need to set the
vision of course I know I need to
business develop I I understand but
man every
organization you know how they say
You're only as happy as your most
unhappy
child I think about that at Vayner media
I believe that we are only as strong as
the person that's least happy there and
I address it constantly batter it batter
it I spent this week in London and like
we just I mean it was like I said
something off the cuff CU I addressed
the whole company globally out of London
this week to kick off the year and I
said this is a family business not a
corporation and the more that you
believe me and the more that we act like
that the more we will win and I think
you know for a lot of people in this
audience they don't know enough to know
how real this is to me for you because
you interact with my team you can
believe what I'm saying more but that
front row they know I'm telling the
truth right and
so that's how I live my life I want to
be I want to be liked more by the people
that really know me versus the people
that know of
me okay yeah and I appreciate that and I
I think about that a lot because I think
the world's confused I think there's a
lot of popular people in the world that
are incredibly disliked by the people
around them yeah it's so true right that
that was a weird thing that happened to
me when I got into The High Ground of
society and interacted with like really
fancy people I was devastated by that
people that are perceived in public as
like awesome are like poisonous to their
people then how do those people keep
being successful
fear humans weaponize fear
fear is incredibly
powerful it stops almost everybody
that's listening to this right now from
doing the thing they want so a lot of
people that work for these famous people
or people EV accolades don't think
people will believe them they're scared
they're scared that if they leave that
power person is so powerful it will
screw them up fear fear is the single
worst thing in the world and it is
weaponized constantly
by businesses by
politicians by
governments and worst of all by
parents so I just want to go back to the
CEO thing what should CEO stop
doing that's a good question I mean look
the first one was so easy cuz it was so
I feel it's so uncomfortably Universal
the second one is why I love having
Vayner media we get to work with so many
businesses and the truth is there's a
different answer for a lot of things you
know public
CEOs need to stop worrying about just
their
pockets if you really are educated about
public companies and you're really into
this I can almost predict what most
companies are going to do based on my
intuition of how much longer that CEO
plans on being in their role if I
believe a CEO is looking to retire in
two years I know the next two years the
stock price is going to go way up CU
they're going to cut costs at all costs
because they have two years to get it up
as high as they can and then they have
another six months that they have to
wait and then they're going to sell all
their shares to buy their boat and their
Island and their Jet and their
life and that usually means that's in
direct contrast to actually growing the
business because you're cutting cost not
investing in
growth right so that's a public CEO
and I think some of them should care
more about the Legacy if they spent
those last two years building the crap
out of the business they might be able
to hold on to the stock longer than the
six months and actually get double of
the money by setting up the next CEO to
let them keep going but I get how human
behavior works I understand they've
worked hard they want to enjoy their
last 15 years it all really nothing that
happens in the world doesn't make sense
to me but I would say that's one thing I
I think the other thing they should do
is stop underestimating their
competitors think there's a lot of
delusion meaning they shouldn't fixate
on their competitors but we live in a
world where the speed and change is so
high that even if you think you've got a
moat an advantage it is vulnerable at
all times because the speed of
innovation is unparalleled so just a
little less naive like were this that's
nice but IBM was that and then Microsoft
came along and then Microsoft was that
and then Google came along and then
Google was that and then Facebook came
along like the biggest companies in the
world always go out of business or
decline but then I guess you know we
talked about money making money if if
that's the objective and and where some
people I think value it or will Define
your success on money is will that
always drive businesses and drive you
know what CEOs do and and their main
objective you know I look I think money
is a very fascinating thing and as a
human being I'm so grateful that I got
lucky and parented well and
circumstances didn't allow me to put
that thing on a pedestal on the flip
side money is oxygen for business I'm a
pretty altruistic foofy foofy let's all
love each other guy but if I can't make
payroll all my good ideas aren't going
to matter
anyway so I think that this one you have
to be a little careful with do I believe
a CEO cfo's function is to make money
yes I do cuz you can't do anything if
you don't and I love business it's like
sports like I want to make money I don't
think it's a bad thing I think like
anything in life when it gets out of
balance You're vulnerable and I think
the world has become incredibly red and
Incredibly blue and I think all the
magic is
purple there's a lot of purple in this
room which I like I'm I'm obsessed with
purple is it you
my favorite color is green because of
the New York Jets but but I've become
incredibly fascinated with purple as the
world has become incredibly fixated on
being only either red or blue and I I
think that's a big
mistake um lots of people know you from
social media you have got a huge
following um and on social media so I
watch it and I'm like oh my gosh he said
that and you are
unashamedly out there you
say what you what you feel and sometimes
it's uncomfortable to watch yeah but I
guess that's what you want in a way are
you saying what people feel or is it
just not you're not saying it to make
anyone feel uncomfortable you're saying
I'm definitely not saying it to make
people uncomfortable yeah but you're
just saying the facts this if you want
your business to do well you got to do
this this is not working I am saying the
thing that I feel in my stomach
could provide the most value to the most
people at this exact
second and so because I read so many
comments and emails I tend to have a
good
pulse I think it's one of the biggest
mistake that content creators make they
don't engage or read the comments or
engage so they lose touch with I know
people who say you need to delete all
the comments or they don't want to see
anything negative well that's because
they're incredibly insecure yeah I
actually spend a lot of time thinking
through when I get negative feedback I'm
always scared to get too high on myself
so I'm checking myself I'm like are they
right and often times they're not
they're just I mean think about the life
of someone who goes around to someone
else's content on the internet and says
negative things I'm not mad at that
person I feel sad for that person I
actually have a lot of compassion for
people who are incredibly negative
online they're using that as their
outlet for the pain that's in their
stomach um but I just say the things
that are are very clear to me with the
hope that it provides value for
someone did you see that just flash up
as soon as you said that yes 10 minutes
to
finish is that okay so please looking to
the teacher what's on the cards for Gary
and the v x
brand
um
obviously they're two separate entities
for Vayner X my marketing holding
company I'm going to build the largest
marketing company in the
world um so that's good yeah and that
will but that will take time but that's
my
goal um I'm always planning on keeping
it independent I didn't know anything
about Madison Avenue or agencies I
didn't realize the reason there wasn't
really great ones is because as soon as
you get great a little bit you sell to
wpp or romcom orist and so the holding
companies take the good ones off the
table because the entrepreneurs that
build them want the money I got lucky I
didn't want the money I wanted a
marketing company for myself to do my
other behaviors I used my marketing
company to help build resi which is a
company I built and sold I used it to
build empathy wines which is a company I
built and sold I'm using it to build
vriends you know the talent from it went
to vend so I kind of needed it as my
operating system
so I plan on doing that and then for me
you know it's hard because I'm a counter
puncher meaning I'm not if I was a boxer
I'm not Mike Tyson I'm not attacking
something and going at it I was I'm more
Floyd Mayweather I'm watching what's
coming at me and I'm adjusting so I
don't know what technology is going to
come up next year or what might happen
in society in four years but I'm gonna
see it because that's what I do and then
I'm then I may do something about it and
so I have no clue what I'm what business
I may start or what I might go after in
three or four when the nft thing
happened I had no idea that I was going
to start my Pokemon Sesame Street brand
called be friends that was not what I
was planning on doing but when I saw the
opportunity of this new platform I was
like Hey I've always wanted to do
something like this and then I spent the
year thinking and building and that's
how I got there so and is that exciting
for you to sort of just going the flows
yeah yeah it's
incredibly um
peaceful it's very nice uh I know I use
a lot of sports anales I apologize it's
what I know but sometimes you hear from
a a obviously in this country a football
player a basketball player you know
where they talk about how that're almost
inevitably they talk about why are you
so great and they talk about that moment
where the game slowed
down and what they're referring to is
actually they're just Pro processing and
and are physically
faster for me business and life is
slow I can just see it all it's easy for
me to move in it so what of it's
incredibly peaceful because I'm never
caught off
guard well finally you are in a room
full of Business Leaders here if there's
just one thing they should take away
from our chat today what would you want
it to
be that regret is
poison that if I could wish anything on
this audience or the one that's
listening at home besides health for
them and their loved ones it would be
for them to get the clarity at this
exact second that this is the piece of
content that gave them the clarity that
almost every decision that they make in
life definitely professionally and
predominantly if not definitely in their
personal life should be to mitigate
regret in their 80s and
90s I think way too many people in this
room have compromised being happy or
going after a
goal to check the box on paying a
mortgage or being practical when if they
had the humility to take a step
backwards including things like selling
a home to pay off the mortgage and keep
the extra profit to go rent an apartment
so that he could quit their job or
change course and go at something that
would bring them Joy until the world
redefines success in not materialistic
things in money but to being joyful and
happy for as much of a percentage of
their breathing time as possible we will
continue to make these Mees missteps and
so
the thing I would leave you all with
is go spend more time with people that
are 80 and 90 that are not your
relatives and and talk to them and you
will clearly see what I just talked
about the last two minutes is the number
one thing that you should focus on every
day of your life and that about fear
it's all fear and the tough one about
taking a step back like selling your
home and the only reason somebody
doesn't do that if they even realize to
do it to get get happy is they're scared
of the Judgment from the people in their
family or their friends oh you're so not
successful that you had to sell your
house or you're so crazy you're going to
start this Pie Company when you have
this great job and you're selling your
home to do it how could you do that to
your children when people don't realize
houses are too big and if you move into
an apartment you're more likely to spend
more time with your children it's even
better I'm serious about these things
like we have so many things is
[Music]
wrong